Hello, my name is Anna Duensing, I'm a
PhD candidate at Yale University, working
on a dissertation about antifascism
within the civil rights movement and Black
radical theories of fascism in
the United States from the 1930s
onward.
And today, as part of the Fortunoff
Video Archives commemoration of
Black History Month, I'd like to talk
to you about one aspect of that research
which concerns African-American military
service during World War II
and more generally, how soldiers and
veterans have contributed to
the Black freedom struggle across the 20th
century.
And within that work, I want to
elevate the experiences of African-American
GIs who confronted Nazi Germany firsthand
and those who really at the heart
of that experience, were eyewitness to the
end stages and immediate aftermath
of the Holocaust.
And for the most part, these men
are known as liberators today.
That refers to soldiers who pushed into
the crumbling Third Reich in the spring
and summer of 1945 and who
encountered the Buchenwald,
Dora-Mittelbau, Flossenbürg,
Dachau, and Mauthausen concentration
camps.
And the Fortunoff is home to the remarkable
testimony of one such soldier.
His name was Leon Bass.
Bass was also a lifelong educator
who spent the last four and a half decades
of his life up until his death
in 2015.
He spent those those years speaking out
about his military experience
and what it meant for him to witness
Buchenwald while serving in
a segregated Army.
Really have subsequent decades
of reckoning with the Holocaust contributed
to his interest in education,
his involvement in the civil rights
movement, and more generally, how the
experience of witnessing this
aspect, this culmination
of Nazi persecution, shaped
his understanding subsequently of
U.S. race relations and
more generally, the realities
of ongoing racial violence and white
supremacy in the United States.
Now, Leon Bass was born and raised in
Philadelphia.
He grew up in a predominantly Black
neighborhood. He went to all Black schools
and he describes his parents
who were sharecroppers, former
sharecroppers from South Carolina.
They had kept him relatively sheltered from
the full force and structural
violence of racism and Jim Crow
segregation in the United States.
However, all that changes for him when he
joins the army.
Twenty years old by the time the Second
World War had become a reality.
No, I was--I, I finished
school in 1943 and I was eighteen.
And that's when I became part of the
military.
And you-- how did you become part of the
military? Did you volunteer or you were
drafted?
Yes. I went out and I, I volunteered
and I was to go out with the next group.
And when I went down to the induction
center, institutional
racism smacked me right in the face
because the sergeant was
there and he told me
to go one way.
When I went through the door and he told my
white friends to go another way because
my country practices promulgated
and promoted institutional
racism and the military was one of the
largest to do just that.
And so I went into an all Black
unit, save for the officers, they were
white.
But all of my comrades
in arms at the time were Black.
Induction marked the start of a brutal
new kind of education for him,
beginning with two hard and disaffecting
rounds of basic training in
the Jim Crow South.
This was first in Georgia, later in
Mississippi, followed by manoeuvers in
Texas, Louisiana and Arkansas.
And this extended training was actually
typical for African-American GIs,
the majority of whom were trained in combat
before they were reassigned and retrained
in unarmed labor units.
And Bass was assigned to the
183rd Combat Engineers.
And this was a time when, as with civilian
life, formal and informal color
lines snaked across every
aspect of military service.
White soldiers, lynch mobs, vigilante
groups, numerous iterations
of state and local, civic and law
enforcement agencies.
They all policed these lines as they saw
fit.
At the same time, Jim Crow lawmakers at the
state and federal levels vowed
to defend the social and political order of
Jim Crow at whatever cost.
Even U.S. blood banks remain segregated
at this time, which was a hold out of
explicit racial science so egregious,
so parallel to Nazi race law that
it became one of the most heated
civil rights issues of the war years.
And in the case of the armed forces that
the stress and strain and insult of
these color lines became particularly
intensified.
Second class citizenship is not tolerable
to someone in uniform, someone who is
risking his life for his country.
And many African-Americans at this time had
observed distinct connections between
Nazism and Jim Crow, had recognized
the parallels on the basis of racism,
white supremacy, militarism,
empire, and attacks on organized
labor.
So the patriotic rhetoric of the war
and fighting in defense of democracy,
the framing of World War II as a war
of good versus evil, freedom versus
tyranny, to many African-Americans, this
appeared hypocritical and rather
fraudulent.
Was it your perception, though, that the
Black troops generally, though,
fully understood the fact that
while the rhetoric of the war against Nazi
racism and so forth was fine,
in practice, the country was doing
something entirely different?
Yes, it was as though you were
schizophrenic.
Our country had-- was two personalities.
You know, in one way we may make the
wonderful pronouncements.
You know, we we talk about our
Judeo-Christian ethics and we're going to
make the world a better place for democracy
and all that other jazz.
But then when you get down to the real
thing and you start seeing the way they
operate, you
know, things were not, they were not in
consonance.
And so I began
to be an angry, frustrated young
Black soldier.
At this time, I wanted to get out of the
army.
I'll be very honest with you.
After my experiences, I really did not
want to be in this man's army
and...
Especially after having to stand
on a bus when
there were no seats in the back, having to
stand up for 100 miles, looking at empty
seats.
That didn't endear me to,
to my country.
I couldn't eat in a restaurant.
I had to go around the back and knock on
the door to get food.
And I'm in a uniform.
And I saw PWs, prisoners
of war from Germany being
allowed to go in a restaurant to sit down
to eat. And yet I was not entitled to that
same opportunity.
Bass's battalion shipped out from Europe in
October 1944 and connected
with the U.S. 3rd Army in Belgium,
where they were part, they fought as part
of the Battle of the Bulge, which was the
last major German offensive campaign
on the Western Front.
And as laborers, soldiers like Bass
were first on the front lines.
They were building roads and bridges.
They were loading equipment and supplies,
disabling landmines, moving
the wounded and the dead.
And Bass's battalion crossed into Germany
in March of 1945.
And by April, they had reached the central
German city of Weimar.
We, we went to Weimar, set
up our bivouac area, and then
went immediately with an officer,
about five of us.
We were in the intelligence reconnaissance
section of our unit and we went
right to Buchenwald.
And that was the day that I was
to discover what had really been going
on in Europe under the Nazis.
Because I walked through the gates
and I saw walking
dead people.
Seriously, walking dead people.
I am not a doctor.
I cannot assess things
that accurately. But in just looking
at these people who were skin and bone
and...
dressed in those pajama type uniforms,
their heads clean shaved, and
filled with sores due to malnutrition,
and here they were coming towards us,
making all kinds of guttural
statements and using their own language.
And it was very difficult for me to
comprehend what was going on.
I just looked at this in amazement and,
and I said to myself,
you know, my God,
you know, who are these people?
What have they done,
what was their crime?
You know, it's hard for me to try
to understand why anybody could have
been treated this way and I don't care what
they had done, just didn't
grab me.
And I didn't have any way of thinking,
of putting a handle on it.
No frame of reference.
I was only 20.
When U.S. forces discovered Buchenwald,
they found over 21,000
people imprisoned there.
And the days before their arrival, the
Germans had attempted to evacuate some
30,000 others, roughly
a third of whom perished in the process.
The earliest inmates at Buchenwald, which
opened in 1937, were political
prisoners. But the German SS and police
had sent many Jews there, alongside Roma,
Jehovah's Witnesses, military deserters,
repeat criminals, and others,
other groups.
And at the end of the war, Buchenwald was
one of roughly 44,000
camps, ghettos and incarceration
sites operated by Nazi Germany
and its allies across Europe.
Terms like Auschwitz and Bergen-Belsen,
Majdanek and places like that were not,
were not known to you.
Even when I went into Buchenwald, I had no
idea that those places existed.
Those names only came to me after
I got out of the service.
Later, much later,
I began to hear of names and places
and realized that there was more than just
a Buchenwald, that they were
many, many, many Buchenwalds of different
names all over Europe
and in Russia.
And that's what boggles
the mind, to think that's, a group
that society can organize and do it in
a systematic way, such a
program.
To remove from
the world a whole group of people
and any others that didn't seem, they
didn't think were worthy.
Like many of his comrades,
Bass initially experienced a kind of
numbness about what he had seen.
Military intelligence had not prepared
soldiers for the realities of the camps.
And within weeks, Bass was shipped off to
the Philippines to finish his service.
And upon return to the United States, he
set forth to build a life, all the while
keeping silent about what he had seen.
He started a family, pursued a Ph.D.,
built his career, and became involved
with the civil rights movement.
And years later, the assassination of
Dr. Martin Luther King in 1968
shook him to the core.
It had a profound impact on him.
And in his testimony, he describes the
heartache and horror he felt
in its wake, particularly when
he confronted the pain and disillusionment
of many of the young Black and brown
students at the high school where he served
as a principal.
And one day, these present
realities in the United States and his
memories of the war collided
when a visitor came to one of his
classrooms.
And one day I came to a classroom,
and in that classroom there was a lady
and she was trying to talk to the young men
who were not listening to her,
you know, they doing everything but
listening.
And I stood at the door and I began to
realize that she was a survivor
and she had survived one of the worst
camps. She had survived Auschwitz.
And she was here today, on this particular
day to share her experience, her pain,
if you will.
And these young men were not listening.
They had their own pain, you know, and
I understood that, you know, the pain of
rejection, the pain of not giving, being
given the kind of recognition you deserve.
I understood all of that.
I had been through there, and
I knew their pain, but I also knew
her pain.
And so I had to say to them, hold it,
fellas, cool it.
Listen, what she says
is true. I was there.
And so they got quiet for a while.
And once she started telling
her account of what happened at Auschwitz,
they really listened.
And she told them how she lost her
grandmother. Grandfather.
Her parents, brothers, sisters, cousins,
all those near and dear who had come into
that camp, all of them had
gone to the gas chambers and had ended
up in the ovens.
And of her family, she was the only one
that came out of there.
And they listen, she
shared with them so much.
And they ask her questions, which made me
know that she
had to reach them.
They came up and looked at the numbers
tattooed on her arm and
they thanked her
and they did something that hadn't done in
a long while. They left that room in
silence.
And, of course, she turned to me and of
course, tears were coming down her face.
And she thanked me for my intervention
and
wanted to know more about my
experience at Buchenwald.
And I began to remember.
Bass's experience was unique,
but what he made of that experience and
how he and his words began to hook
things together in subsequent decades
is instructive for us all.
Bass's memories of military service and
camp liberation, and how those memories
came to bear on his interpretation of
racism in the United States.
It results in a call for unity.
His testimony concludes with a call for an
antiracist coalition building
force.
But he also closes with a call for
vigilance.
The Holocaust forced a global moral
reckoning.
In the United States, it was a tipping
point that compelled many white Americans
to examine the state of their own country
and to get behind African-Americans demands
for fundamental civil and human rights.
But the realities of the Holocaust also
played a significant part in forcing white
supremacists to abandon the
most explicit and chauvinist
articulations of their worldviews,
right, lest they be associated with the
unsightly backwardness of
the recent war.
And it's significant that Bass reengaged
with his memories of Buchenwald around
1970.
Formal narratives and institutions of
Holocaust memory were on the rise in the
United States around that time.
But as he so delicately puts it in
his testimony, this was a moment
when many of the promises of civil rights
had begun to falter.
And the government and many white
Americans were clearly coming up short
in the project of reflection
and reckoning, the project of dismantling
and rebuilding their racist foundations.
And Bass saw that failure.
He saw it in the refusal,
you know, of his community to change, but
most especially among his young students.
Really, Bass's memories open up the
possibility of productive comparison
toward solidarity and racial justice.
He asked us to consider not only
what changed after 1945, but
also what attitudes and cultures stayed the
same and,
in particular, stayed the same, cloaked
or carried on in innuendo or
in action.
And as an educator, Bass concludes his
testimony with an important lesson
for us all.
And look what it did to us.
Racism has just about split us so many
different ways that we can't live in
harmony with one another, suspicious.
All of this I discovered
as an adult and I didn't get it when I
was young, when I should have had it
because people didn't want to deal with it.
It was an ugly side of our history and ugly
things we want to push under the rug.
We don't want to deal with it.
And I'm saying to people today, you must
face it.
You can't laundry and sanitize our history.
You must take history with its beauty and
you must take it with its degradation.
You've got to deal with it, for us to
be whole human beings and and to make a
difference. And it's especially true with
young people.
And so I go around telling my
story. And, of course, I, you know, I get
the people saying, Leon, what
do you deal with this? This is, this is not
a Black problem.
I said, hey, it's not a Black problem.
It's not a white problem.
It's a human problem.
And we've got to face it.
And as Dr. King said, injustice
anywhere is the loss
of justice everywhere.
You see words to that effect
and it's true. What affects you, affects
me. Your pain has to be my pain and my
pain has to be your pain.
And I must somehow convey that to the young
people that I come to.
It's my commitment and somebody
says you, why do you deal with
that mess? You know, I said, I'm sorry.
I know it's been 40 something years,
but that doesn't make it go away.
It only makes us become more aware
that we today have to do something that
to stop that which created
the Final Solution and
that something is racism,
really racism is at the root of
all of this. Under that umbrella comes
bigotry and prejudice and discrimination,
unemployment, people who are unemployable,
large institutions filled with those who
are drug addicts and those who are
criminals, or because somehow we have
come to grips with that institution called
racism, and we have
to because we see the ultimate of racism,
which was what I saw at Buchenwald.
And so what do we do?
Do we as educators, and
I use it in the broadest sense because we
are all teachers of the young and in
our way of life,
do we convey to them
the best that we can be,
or do we give them the worst
side that we have?
Do we promote racism
through our apathy?
When we hear and see things, we say nothing
because we don't want to jeopardize that
which is important to us.
Our investment in a job, our investment
among friends.
We don't want to disturb our families.
So no matter what people say
or do, just leave it alone, sweep
it under the rug and somehow it'll go away.
But the skinheads are with us.
The Klan is with us.
It may be dressed in Brooks Brothers suit
with attaché cases.
They may be in, in, doctors,
they may be lawyers. They may be the guy
who drives the bus, but they are still with
us.